[Music]
turning now to covid coverage more than
1300 positive covid19 cases have been
reported in the clark county school
district since july first 1100 of those
were reported just this month now some
parents now are wondering when their
younger children could be eligible for
the vaccine katie houston is live in the
newsroom tonight with their reaction
kate
yes sasha right now pfizer is the only
company offering a covit 19 vaccine for
children 12 and older but some parents
say they're ready for a vaccine to be
authorized for even younger kids to help
bring down case numbers in schools they
are back in person i'm a little bit
nervous about it within the first month
of the new school year the clark county
school district has confirmed more than
1100 covet 19 cases andy block would
like his young daughters to be
vaccinated with delta it spreads so much
more rapidly and easier and
i've seen cases
skyrocket out of the approximately 1300
cases reported since july first nearly
600 of those are in elementary schools a
majority of those being students we're
so desperate it's so frustrating elaine
vigno's son has kidney disease and turns
12 in december she started homeschooling
him right before the pandemic and kept
him at home this year as well we can't
get him the vaccine
and we don't feel like school is safe
for him right now it's just too risky
pfizer is currently studying the safety
of the covid 19 vaccine in children 6
months to 11 years old block is now
urging the company to release some data
so parents with young kids can begin
having these discussions unfortunately
in las vegas our cases have leveled off
a little bit were not the highest risk
in the country but it's still very
elevated risks higher risks and then i
feel very comfortable about sending my
kids out to do all the normal activities
that they do if approved pfizer plans to
submit the vaccine for emergency use
authorization for ages 5 to 11 sometime
between september and october we're
getting everyone vaccinated and my son
is like alone
the lone one left out
and it's just
it's sad
well currently 25 thousand out of 42
thousand school district staff have
uploaded their vaccination cards the
school district is now considering
mandating vaccinations for all employees
a resolution will be voted on during a
special school board meeting this
wednesday back to you sasha
okay thank you well you can now get your
covid vaccine at three clark county dmv
locations in the evenings these include
the offices on sahara flamingo and
decatur hours are 6 30 to 10 30 on
fridays 4 30 to 8 30 on saturdays and
sundays and 6 30 until 10 30 on mondays
if you missed any of that information we
know it's a lot we have it for you on
our website 8newsnow.com